i'm here today to share some really good  tips on organizing your pantry so tip  number one is to create zones so  i created for my family a breakfast zone  dinner  snacks and sweet treats it really goes  from most used to least used and i love  that my kids can kind of access this  level  tip number two is to categorize  everything and place it in a bin or a  container and it's kind of a must for us  to label so that everybody knows where  to put things back  and tip number three is really just for  you um when you're making that grocery  list make sure that you come over to  your actual pantry and make the list by  looking inside you'll  trust me you're going to save a ton of  time and money when you go to the  grocery store then happy organizing